私はじめシャツは面倒くさがりでお掃除が
第一来那
いやあああそうお前が日常生活で最も嫌いと言ってもの3つ一つ選択2つお料理3つ
放送人なのだ
you are ことなんかぐうたらな僕でもね何もせずに掃除してくれるものを買っ
てきました2人こちら妄想0
ベイヤーのキレイを装置ロー
バカでしょ大谷見つけてしまったんまぁより安くやって滑走路さんいれば僕学校で
パティそうしてくれるわけなのだ
ん
ヨーン分ばと勝てない高石さあ壊したりしたら嫌だからあまり開脚9分
新こういうカスねこんな感じですね大丈夫かねそれにこういうたかモップがついてて
これが自分でボックっつけろってことか
あっこれで取り外しができて校で護衛感じだなあこういう感じで
この点灯部署夫とのバトルとぞタイヤカバー
がこれ co2にこの多分外すと太陽が出てくるわけだライター
すすめ持ってくれたこれで多分もう押せば動き出します
グー
def
[音楽]
ブーバーちゃんとしてるんじゃないのって思ったり動いてますよだーうちゃんと想像し
てるか r あー2路線使う女性
あってしまったようだ
こちらぜ俺の部屋に放つそして奏上してもらう俺が想像することは今後一生なくなるだ
ブーブーひんぬー
あれ
ラーと終了はいと夕食総二郎も全部出しましたここで俺はあることに気付いた
間違いなく普通に措置したを早いということを
なあ
相次ぎデヘアが本当に綺麗に誰かどうかを分かりやすくするためにティッシュを細くし
たから前ておきます混ぜこいつらにこのティッシュは掃除する能力があるのかどうか
そこが今回の見所ですねはい結構強まりました
これで親子を操縦する必要がない連れてこいつら宗次郎が掃除してくれる
では早速そう
してもらおうと思います
go
ああああああああああああ
ああああああ
ああああああああ
ran
rar
ています
re ある
[音楽]
ana b 2
しています